cómo puede cristalizar una tendencia social o un evento complejo
de una manera que muchas palabras no lo podrían hacer,
y reducirlo a su esencia y convertirlo en una caricatura.
Así que fui a la biblioteca
y miré la primera portada dibujada por Rea Irvin en 1925,
un dandy mirando una mariposa a través de su monóculo,
y lo llamamos Eustace Tilley.
Y me di cuenta de que, como la revista se había hecho conocida
por su investigación en profundidad y largos informes,
se había perdido en el camino algo del humor
ya que, a menudo, a Eustace Tilley se le veía como un dandy altivo,
pero, de hecho, en 1925,
cuando primero Rea Irvin dibujó esta imagen,
lo hizo como parte de una revista de humor
para divertir a la juventud de la época,
que eran los flappers de los rugientes años veinte.
Y en la biblioteca,
encontré las imágenes que realmente capturaron el espíritu del tiempo
de la Gran Depresión.
Y nos mostró no solo cómo vestía la gente
o cómo se veían sus autos,
sino también qué los hacía reír,
cuáles eran sus prejuicios.
Y realmente uno capta el sentimiento
de lo que era estar vivo en los años 30.
Así que llamé a artistas contemporáneos,
como Adrian Tomine.
A menudo llamo a artistas narrativos,
dibujantes, autores de libros infantiles...
y les doy temas como,
ya saben, qué significa estar en el metro,
o el Día de San Valentín,
y ellos me envían bocetos.
Y una vez que los bocetos son aprobados por el editor,
David Remnick,
es una oportunidad.
Y amo el camino
esas imágenes en realidad no te dicen qué pensar.
Pero te hacen pensar,
porque, en realidad, el artista es...
es casi un rompecabezas;
el artista dibuja puntos,
y el lector tiene que completar la imagen.
Y, para obtener esta imagen a la izquierda de Anita Kunz,
o la de la derecha de Tomer Hanuka,
hay que jugar a detectar las diferencias.
Y es algo que...
es realmente emocionante de ver:
cómo el compromiso con el lector,
cómo esas imágenes realmente capturan
y juegan con los estereotipos.
Pero cuando las ves,
reorganizan los estereotipos que están en nuestra cabeza.
Pero las imágenes no solo tienen que mostrar a la gente,
a veces puede ser un sentimiento.
Justo después del 11 de septiembre,
estaba en un punto,
como todos los demás,
donde realmente no sabía cómo lidiar con lo que estábamos pasando,
y sentí que ninguna imagen podría capturar este momento,
y quería hacer una portada negra,
como sin cobertura.
Y hablé con mi esposo, el dibujante Art Spiegelman,
y le mencioné que iba a proponer eso,
y él dijo: "Oh, si vas a hacer una portada negra,
entonces ¿por qué no haces la silueta de las Torres Gemelas,
negro sobre negro?".
Y me senté a dibujar esto,
y tan pronto como lo vi,
un escalofrío corrió por mi espina dorsal
y me di cuenta
de que en este rechazo a hacer una imagen,
habíamos encontrado una manera de capturar la pérdida
el luto
y la ausencia.
Y ha sido algo profundo lo que he aprendido en el proceso.
A veces algunas de las imágenes que dicen más
hay que hacerlas con el menor de los medios disponibles.
Y una imagen simple puede hablar volúmenes.
Esta es la imagen que publicamos de Bob Staake
justo después de la elección de Barack Obama,
y capturó un momento histórico.
Pero realmente no podemos planear esto,
porque para hacer esto,
hay que dejar que el artista experimente las emociones que todos sentimos
cuando eso está sucediendo.
Así que en noviembre de 2016,
durante las elecciones del año pasado,
la única imagen que podíamos publicar era esta,
que estuvo en el estrado la semana que todos votaron.
(Risas)
Porque sabíamos que alguien sentiría eso,
cuando se anunciara el resultado de las elecciones.
Y cuando se dieron los resultados,
realmente estábamos perdidos.
Y esta es la imagen que Bob Staake envió nuevamente,
y eso realmente dio en el blanco.
Y otra vez,
no podemos realmente entender lo que vendrá después.
Pero aquí se sentía como si no supiéramos cómo seguir adelante,
pero avanzamos.
Y esta es la imagen que publicamos después de la elección de Donald Trump
y en el momento de la Marcha de Mujeres
en todo Estados Unidos.
Entonces durante esos 24 años,
he visto cobrar vida a más de 1000 imágenes semana tras semana,
y a menudo me preguntan cuál es mi favorita,
pero no puedo elegir una
porque lo que más me enorgullece es lo diferente que es cada imagen,
una de otra.
Y eso se debe al talento y la diversidad
de todos los artistas que contribuyen.
Y ahora, bueno,
ahora, somos propiedad de Rusia,
así que...
(Risas)
En una representación de Barry Blitt aquí,
Eustace se convirtió en Eustace Vladimirovich Tilley.
Y la mariposa no es otra que un estupefacto Donald Trump
batiendo sus alas,
tratando de descubrir cómo controlar el efecto mariposa,
y el famoso logotipo que fue dibujado por Rae Irvin en 1925
ahora está en cirílico.
Entonces, lo que realmente me emociona de este momento
es ver la forma en que
la libertad de prensa es esencial para nuestra democracia.
Y podemos ver desde lo sublime hasta lo ridículo
que los artistas pueden capturar lo que está pasando
de una manera que un artista
armado solo con tinta china y acuarela
puede capturar e incentivar el diálogo cultural.
Pone a esos artistas en el centro de esa cultura,
y eso es exactamente donde creo que deberían estar.
Porque lo que de verdad necesitamos ahora es una buena caricatura.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)